have a good time that's up to the sky we
got a spark I'm counting down yeah we
play up to the sky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking in the sky
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
morning Millennials I'm sorry I forgot
that we were on the air
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday happy
hump day don't forget to hump someone
you love today whether it's your dog I
met hump your boot looks like a furry
little friend
yes made of Thea's cousins no I'm
kidding it's fake its fake its fake its
fake it's a joke joke can't joke like
that a joke a joke a joke total joke how
is Theo though he's good he got into
some duty yesterday so and then he also
ate a little bit of penne alla vodka for
dinner last night because I was asleep
and then let him get into the pene so
Theo is having diarrhea today for those
who are just wondering about his regular
bowel movements I think absolutely
everyone is wondering about Theo and his
bowel movements like he's the precious
gem he's usually very regular by the way
we never got any feedback on if people
wanted Co to start a patreon I'm sorry
that's incorrect
I saw one person who said they wanted to
okay so you guys see I was gonna start a
patreon channel where basically we just
live-streaming camera on him for an hour
a month it'll be lit by brushes I think
like like four okay six business room
that's $75 he has bills to pay he has
medical supplies to acquire it is a
beautiful day here in New York thank God
our stream is looking bright and sunny
and so is my back and it's nice and
sweaty it's like it's the weather has
become such an integral part of my life
and I'm so grateful when it's like sunny
and stuff but my back gets so hot oh so
it's like it's a win-lose hot back
syndrome HB s HB s um good morning
everyone there's so much to talk about
today it's like I don't even know where
to start I guess we'll start with the
fact that cam toes tickets went up for
pre-sale yesterday the the tickets are
flooding in the hip and snatch the group
is popping off already like everyone is
being so cute already making friends
already making connections but don't
also think like it's too late to make no
it's no it's not they started like a
group me for people who are going alone
so that like when you roll up and you
want to turn around because you're like
why did I show up to Internet camp alone
like you text this other solo people and
like you guys
find your people that is so cute I
didn't see that I love when like a new
group gets started it gets me like
really excited yeah and especially at
camp group cuz like yeah right now we're
strangers on the Internet but we're soon
going to become best friends right and
that's the thing about camp there are no
strangers here just friends you haven't
met yet and just counselors you haven't
met a beautiful quote a beautiful quote
beautiful quote from camp toast um okay
so do we bet we're gonna recap
Vanderpump rules at the end of this
episode and the bachelor since we both
caught up yesterday I went to bed take
about two minutes and as it was so
[ __ ] boring oh I have so many
thoughts um I went to bed at 8:30 which
was just so special like I can't I don't
do that enough you order like randomly
always falling asleep at like 6 p.m.
very random but I'm mostly falling
asleep at 12 yeah but it's just like a
it's such a long night do you know what
I mean like I took a nyquil to because I
was not feeling great yeah sound like
like someone who works a crow at the
wall the long night it was a long night
the White Walkers okay whatever so it's
someone vacuuming during our live show
oh my god the lack of respect is just
out of out of control but yes I took my
quail and I woke up at like 3:00 a.m.
because like I had already been sleeping
for like 7 hours and you just assume
that like it's time to wake up and I was
just thinking myself I lied there for
like 20 minutes before before the night
like I actually was back to sleep and
this is like a very bad children's book
before the long night ended and I was
just thinking myself there's so many
hours in the night you know like if what
if we didn't have to sleep how
productive we would vote for sure it's
just like Rob Pattinson in Twilight
right even all those books he's so
productive so productive yeah from oh oh
my god by the way there are a lot of new
toasters and I've been seeing a lot of
posts in the groups like asking if we
could do like toasty lingo but we have
this teeny lexicon episode on our
patreon it's a two-parter some say it's
our favorite episode ever right where we
explain kind of all the weird [ __ ] we
say yeah and like just tell funny
stories that accompany them well on this
Tosa I'm this on this show we reference
a lot so expensive and that's from the
first ad we ever did when our show was
on the morning breath we got our first
like commercial and it was for a
fabfitfun and it was scripted so we just
had to read it and me and Jackie went in
like this little podcast booth and we
were reading and Jackie just kept
pronouncing the words so we're like
reading off the paper and I was like
normally there
full-size products would be so expensive
then we couldn't get through the whole
thing so now you can't say so without
saying so expensive so expensive um I
watched Vanderpump rules in the bachelor
and then I got into my book and I'm now
like 80% of the way through and clawed
it is crazy
page-turner it's a real page here and I
had to put it down to go to sleep but
hopefully I got to finish what if
somebody's name was page-turner that's
like a very normal page is the name and
turner thank you name Wow do you know
anyone with the last name Turner Tina uh
and cam cam cam cam toes tickets go on
sale for her body today at noon I'm so
excited I think it might sell out like
in the next week we got a lot of
pre-sale I don't think I think it'll
sell out we might open up if you may
open up more spots if Dyke's the demand
is there because we want everyone who
wants to come to the camp dose to be
able to come because that's the only
thing you need to bring with you to camp
toast it's a good attitude that you want
to be there right so do you think there
was anyone there last year who didn't
forgot that at home yes that's one girl
she ended up leaving anyways yeah I feel
like we should get into it because we
have so much to do we also do toasters
yeah let's get into it and I have like
things to do today I'm a really busy
like early afternoon a busy we are no
well I I'm doing Jared frites podcast
and I'm oh he's so excited because I've
been watching his Instagram and he
cracks me up and now I just can't wait
to get into it um I'm sure Caroline's
tonight I can't get tickets Arie it's so
loud ever heard about intimate affair
it really is intimate well I'm really
just like looking to rehearse for my two
shows this week because I got big shows
coming up maybe we practice some new
material so excited to see everyone
we're excited to see it also I love
doing shows at Caroline's because the
food is so [ __ ] good like just like
the chicken fingers and the penne when
you do a theater like there's no menu
you know what I mean I think Theo's
gonna order the penne I have really yeah
I've really missed performing in comedy
clubs you know it's hard when you're
stars like selling out The Beacon
Theater no dream last night by the way
update because they took nyquil I think
maybe it's silence to my inner demons
actually it usually makes your dreams
pop off I know I think sometimes sharing
like your fears like the fact that
you're having dreams about the beacon
like it sometimes it's the way to
overcome them Oh should I talk more
about it okay I'm like so nervous I just
can't help thinking like
never performed in a place that has two
balconies do you know what I mean yeah
have you also never performed in a place
where you've attended like a concert
Huntington OKC Massacre Kacey Musgraves
I saw her there which and honestly I was
really nervous about too because I was
one of my biggest shows but like that's
a good point
also I don't think I have ever performed
where I know that so many people I know
are in the audience like I have I took
like 75 tickets for myself at the Beacon
for like friends and family and then I
know so many people who like bought
their own tickets so I'm just like
nervous about how many people I know but
I think that will make it better because
I know in some of yours I mean some of
the shows that we've gone to I feel like
you sometimes like go and like say like
an inside joke like on the house of the
world yeah and then like it makes it
more fun for us yeah no I'm just like I
can't stress enough like when that
curtain is closing like I'm literally
gonna shower like I'm just so excited
cuz like then we have a party afterwards
and it's like all this work is behind me
like work is so great but finishing work
is even better I mean for me I'm gonna
sharp because I will have a co-host five
days a week and I'm going to be pulling
teeth like NHS that I am and I don't
think I'll be getting strep as much
because I won't be traveling and I
actually made a decision right to the
pediatrician yesterday I think I look at
my tonsils out I think that's not
necessary woman as she said you have
enlarged tonsils like normally and
that's just the one of the prerequisites
for getting your tonsils taken out I do
hate like unnecessary surgery and I've
never gone under anesthesia surgery
really everyone gets in there like a
child no I was just talking to someone
who had them out a few years ago and she
said like the recovery was was brutal oh
really
yeah teeth out now no I thought the
wisdom teeth is like a huge deal you
know the tonsils are huge deal sure I
had just been talking to someone who
just had them out and she was like they
mean she was she a drama queen no no no
she wasn't
look I really wasn't okay um but I feel
like there's something you wanted to say
and I was cutting off left and right
well the thing that you have to say we
didn't say yet oh my god it is I guess
it wasn't time but now it is time to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know yeah you before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast yeah you you um dude of the cab he
just died today episode is brought to
you by one of our best and most exciting
brands here at the morning toast the
reel reel where you can own iconic
luxury items at an unreal value with the
reel reel the leading reseller of
authenticated luxury consignment from
designers like Louis Vuitton Gucci rolex
cartier and hundreds more at up to 90%
off retail shop and consign women's and
men's luxury fashion and street wear as
well as fine jewelry watches art and
home they've new arrivals that come in
daily and every item undergoes to real
reals meticulous authentication process
in fact the real real employees over a
hundred brand specialist gemologist
horologist and art curators from around
the globe who inspect thousands of items
each day to ensure that every item is
authenticated
you can shop luxury the sustainable way
so you don't have to feel guilty go
online download the app or visit one of
their stores in West Hollywood or so
home plus their brand new location at
870 Madison Avenue in New York so Jackie
and I are huge customers at the real
real we both shop and consign there just
really makes my bag today it's from the
rail rail it's really cute Gucci bags
I'm usually wearing something from the
real rail today I'm not know that Gucci
bag is from the real real and I put it
on my Instagram story and like I got so
many messages about it I'm like sorry it
was one of a kind
the real real but if you want to get
that or something similar go online or
download the app you can shop in-store
online on the app and get 20% off select
items with the promo code real Simon van
Kempen I am real that's the real real
calm promo code real for 20% off select
items in store online or download the
app plus they have the white glove
service for free in-home pick up today
if you're looking to consign some of
your items
love it you guys it's a game-changer if
you love fashion and you love finding
like cool things that your friends don't
have like the real real oh and I better
at a better price as as a fashionista
it's imperative that I shop at the real
real yes people are done also know i'm a
maxxinista also everyone wants me to
address the fact that tailors would just
released the trailer for Miss Americana
of course it's like she knew I was busy
yeah she has like the same go time as us
yeah okay well I'll check it out later
and we'll have to recap tomorrow yeah
because we have so much to talk about
today and like we also have need to talk
about the Kim and Kylie video I have so
many thoughts so okay we'll work it in
later first story I'm so excited about
it's like the biggest story of the day
to me but you might have not heard yet
but HBO max has ordered an animated
British Royal Family satire series from
Gary Jannetty had the Prince okay
definition of like in tune with what's
necessary and like taking digital
content and giving it the spotlight that
it deserves
right and Gary when he was on our pup
gets a lot of people might not have
known that he used to and I think still
does right
Family Guy yeah so it's like he's got
animation history he's got royal history
like this is the convergence of all of
his passions know how exciting for him
this is and it's like so topical and
timely and like I feel like the best way
to talk about the royal family like
would be through a cartoon right it's
like Allen Gregory honestly it was
giving me Allen Gregory vibes and then I
was like I feel like Gary Jannetty had
something to do with that I was just
gonna say I wouldn't be surprised if I
found that he was like a producer writer
on Allen Gregory one of the most iconic
one season shows on FX starring Jonah
Hill is the voice of Allen Gregory who
is like this very snotty like rich kid
who was born into two two dads and they
like the dads hate each other it's such
a good job it's such a good show and he
brings his own Pinot Grigio to the
school lunch okay the prince hails from
writer and executive producer Gary
Jannetty based on janetti's Instagram
account the series will take a look at
the Royals through the eyes of Prince
George the eldest child of Prince
William and Princess Princess Kate
Jeanette evil voice Prince George with
other members of the voice cast
including Orlando Bloom as Prince Harry
Oh kondal Oh Rashad is Megan Markel Lucy
punches Kate Middleton tom hollander as
both Prince Philip and Prince Charles
Alan [ __ ] as George's Butler Owen I
won't
George's Butler that's hilarious oh my
god Francis Stila Torres Queen Elizabeth
and you on Rihanna's Prince William 20th
Century Fox television will produce star
studded guys this is like the best TV
news I've received in a while it's gonna
be iconic it's really giving me Island
red great vibes like it's all about
Prince George look at the illustration
Oh Gary is the boisterous sort of Prince
George wait these illustrations are so
funny oh they did the Queen like I'm not
cool with that but it's satire and it's
a joke oh my god the Charlotte and
little George looks so cute this is but
this is just so in tune everyone like
really knowing what's going on it's so
hard to integrate like digital
personalities and into traditional media
yeah I think you are not getting pulled
over no you're not and Gary has like
that background in TV which is why I
feel like this is gonna be a smash
success it's gonna I already know I'm
gonna be on HBO max because they have
friends David Gossip Girl reboot now
they have this and I just I'm getting a
really good feeling at the HP on that I
was ever on the fence about HP Elm
accent honestly I hadn't been convinced
one way or the other this is it for me
like I'm so excited I do hope they they
release a lot of episodes at once like I
want to watch anything week tweak
anymore and I'm just so excited for Gary
and this just seems like exactly what
people should be doing with digital
talent like there's been a lot of
mistakes along the way yep
grace Helbig um busy Phillips and I feel
as though this is it this is it you guys
know we are Natan we have made it I
don't know why I feel like so personally
maybe because I just read his book and I
just want everything the best for who
like championing him now yeah and also
because with Meg's it like this news is
more pertinent than ever I wonder if
like they at least this news in junction
with Mex it I have to think that they
may be sped up the announcement because
there's such a hot topic right now yeah
Megan getting you know paparazzi
everywhere she goes the life so jealous
oh and this is also the second series
that Carrie has in the works at HBO max
because it was previously announced that
Raymond Brad are working on a travel
document and Gary go to together and
that space is based off of Brad's
Instagram stories of Gary trying
everything in France and not like Annie
and the pasta it's just some produced
some executive at HBO Max is a genius
and I just want you to know I see you
and I believe in you and I'm really
proud of you yeah and we're also
available honestly I think it might be
Sarah
Aubrey who is the head of original
content for HBO max Sarah Harris star
she said we are so excited to bring the
world Gary's created on Instagram over
to HBO max where our viewers can
discover what his Instagram fans already
know that George can be hilarious
shocking and surprisingly sweet we can't
wait to see what Gary does with a bigger
canvas to paint on than just a one to
one square love it so cute love it
Congrats just good news all around yeah
I just love starting the day with like
some good news some premium content
knowing that there's premium content in
my future
I couldn't sleep well yes with bad
dreams of course okay next story a
little celeb like dating gossip news
Vanessa Hudgens has been spotted out
with Lakers star Kyle Kuzma after Austin
Butler split okay so her and Austin are
just hitting the ground running which is
making me think they've been broken up
for a while yep also people because we
reported that he was with a society girl
Priscilla Presley in a hotel in
Australia like people were like oh my
god he cheated on her but I do think
that they'd already been broken up for a
while yeah and I've been seeing just
like comments and and rumors that are
completely unfounded saying that she was
the one who cheated on him I don't
believe there's anything here that makes
me think that they were cheating but it
does making me think they've been broken
up for a while
no this is definitely like a post
announcement this is not like a rebound
I think they've been broken up for a
while you've been together for nine
years like you take your time with that
breakup announcement it's not like Chaya
Gerber and Pete Davidson who were
together for seven days so they took one
day right no I mean Charlotte York in
Sex in the City did say it takes half
the amount of time to get over your ex
per the amount like so if you dated for
six months it takes three months when
you're dating for someone for eight
years I think it's unreasonable of you
to take four years so maybe it takes
like really four years to completely get
them out of your brain for sure that's
how I think I've shared this with the
class but that's how I used to feel
about the camp it took me half the time
once I got home that I was at camp to
feel totally settled back in the post
camp slump was so real like oh you had
lice hey you had lights like all your
clothes were everywhere like it was
starting to get cold you to cram the
reading that you didn't do like just
also like get the book and that was
before Amazon so like not only did you
have to admit to your parents that you
didn't get the book in the first place
then you much like go to Barnes & Noble
and like you couldn't try Borders get
the book and then read it
speaking of Barnes and Nobles so much
tea at the book party for Stassi like I
have so many thoughts I have so many
thoughts it was actually a great episode
of inner pearls which made up for the
terrible episode of The Bachelor it was
a good episode because there was drama
but it was a bad episode in the sense
that it didn't bode well for the rest of
the series except the newer people had
an interesting storyline I really need
to talk about they're so problematic now
that I can't like watch the show and
separate them from what we learned last
week well discuss okay next story a
little pink news I love her but she
cannot get behind plastic surgery pink
took to Twitter tried a letter to
herself dear me you're getting older I
see lines especially when you smile your
nose is getting bigger is that a thing
when you get older I hope oh my god
you look and feel weird as you get used
to this new reality but your nose looks
like your kids and your face wrinkles
where you laugh and yeah you idiot you
smoked continued note to self every once
in a while you consider altering your
face and then you watch a show where you
want to see what the person is feeling
and their face doesn't move um I cannot
get behind it I just can't I want my
children to know what I look like when
I'm angry she concluded unfortunate
because I've never really depended on my
looks I've decided that my talent and my
individuality luckylove are more
important than my thought so get on
board because I'm about to age the
old-fashioned way in a tutu ruling [ __ ]
at 30 miles per hour a hundred feet in
the air over 40 yeah okay I love her
I just I don't want a hundred percent
agree with this like I feel very
strongly about the fact and this was the
conversation we were having at dinner I
mean I want yesterday just like about
facetune and plastic surgery like I feel
like if you want to do it do it and if
you don't want to do it don't do it but
having an opinion on other people's
decision whether or not to do it annoys
me and she didn't do that here so I just
like that she's only speaking for
herself anything the most brilliant
thing she said it she's like I know I
haven't gotten to where I've gotten
because I'm the prettiest girl in the
room it's because I'm the most talented
and that's what [ __ ] should always be
about but this conversation like and I
feel like we have it a lot especially
like with like post woke feminism like
he's in feminism just like supporting
other women and like what they want to
do yeah
yeah so I think I don't think that she
is contradicting that at all no not at
all but I think it makes for an
interesting conversation I think it's
important to have people like pink and
role models like pink who are in
altering their looks so that other women
who choose to do that like have someone
like to look up to but I also do think
it's it's important to have these two
and advocates it's important to have
Botox and it's important to have all
three but I think and I'm just now
contradicting myself because you
shouldn't be commenting on what other
women do but women who get plastic
surgery and pretend that they don't like
that's toxic and that's not a good role
model but I don't want to comment on
other women's beauty regimens you know
yes no I'm fine
it depends on the position that you're
in and I do think it is harmful when you
just pretend like your face just changed
this way and that's like the natural
order order of Aging yeah I agree but I
love pink and she's definitely a great
role model for her kids and just for
like women in general she's an icon I'm
so glad she's like still thriving - no
II mean yes iving more than ever
yes better than ever I love her so much
Kelly Clarkson responded to her I saw oh
my like just like my two queens it's not
everyday she said I feel you except for
you know the flying through the air
thing you know what I'll keep it down
I'll keep holding it down on the ground
for us and you keep the air safe
I've always enjoyed teamwork we don't
deserve these two it like interacting
it's so precious and I've said this on
the show once before but like if you're
not following Kelly Clarkson on Twitter
you're not living
all she does is tweet at other
celebrities whether they're speaking to
her or not yeah she just chimed in on
conversations and she's so
you are and like I haven't really heard
a lot about her talk show but I just
really hope it's going well it's going
fabulously she got a season two I'm
always seeing it in the news like she's
making news in in positive ways I think
this is a start of something beautiful
for me no I think it's like it's a
lifelong thing for her also can we talk
really quickly I'm gonna wear I'm all
over the place but I'm Wendy Williams
she said nene leakes texted her
yesterday like five minutes before her
show and said she was quitting Real
Housewives of Atlanta and then um Wendy
Williams like totally blew up her spot
and just like said it on the show I
don't know that Nene wanted her to say
it but they're like good friends and
then she was being so elusive and weird
she was talking to Jerry O'Connell so I
was like the perfect audience for it and
she was like Nene has a secret and if
you all knew it like it's crippling like
if you all knew what like you would be
shocked would feel so bad for her like
and Jerry O'Connell was like it's Greg
doing well cuz you know he had cancer
twice and she was like it's not about
Greg and it she was being so elusive and
weird and I don't know what it is that's
really weird and like if that was my
friend I'd be like what are you doing
yeah but I don't know if any texted her
like don't touch certain people like you
want everyone to know something you text
money Williams for sure but the secret
part would bother me yeah to be all
elusive and you made it sound like music
to a friend who does a talk show five
minutes before she's going on air with
like news that her audience would care
about and then be shocked if she shares
with the class and I'm all cut up on
Real Housewives of Atlanta and I'll give
you really quick down low like I just if
Nene is quitting like I cannot wait like
she is ruining the show she's such a pot
stirrer she doesn't really care about
the women at all she doesn't care about
her relationships with them but that's
not really what I needed to say what I
needed to say and make an official
statement I sang I'm absolutely done
with Kenya more like she has become my
least favorite person on planet earth I
always knew she was mean and I knew she
was kind of conniving and like a little
bit evil but it made for great TV but
what she did in these past few episodes
between Tanya who is so lame and like
losery but I love her she's such a nice
girl like all she wants is everyone to
like go to Toronto and like have the
best time and her coming for her
relationship with Paul and her also
coming for Cynthia Bailey's engagement
like done and I'm really turning a
corner on Eva she did the sweetest thing
like yeah that's just like weird a
history that like she alludes to a lot
but like she is her first daughter with
she calls him the donor and I think he's
like you ever see that movie enough with
Jennifer Lopez I saw half of it where
it's like an abusive husband who keeps
talking you down like he's one of those
he keeps like showing up in places that
she's at and she got meant got married
last year and has been dating Michael
sterling for as long as this baby has
been alive like he's basically this
kid's father until last night on last
night's episode they like formally
changed her last name just sterling and
he's gonna adopt her and it was actually
really sweet and I just thought it was
like a nice how all the girls came and
like showed up for her so I'm really
enjoying Real Housewives of Atlanta and
I just want to say like I'm not here for
Kenya Moore and you selling natural
haircare products when loci are wearing
a wig the shade is real she like she's
like um she's been telling everyone for
years that she doesn't wear wigs and all
the women like they all wear wigs they
all wear extensions they have weaves
they all show up looking amazing every
with different hair styles and even last
year they had a natural hair party where
they all had to come with their natural
hair and Kenya Moore and that's like
died on the hill saying all of her hair
is natural she is amazing hair then I
went to Toronto and she left something
at the hotel so one of the girls was
still there and she called Tania I was
like I left something out the hotel it's
at the lobby it's like a little package
when you bring it so Chyna said of
course but it was like this this is like
taped up box and they were going across
the border and tani was like my
boyfriend was like we have to open it
I'm not gonna take like it's littered
what they tell you at the airport one
can pack did you pack your own item
right so she opens it and there's a wig
in there oh my god and it was just like
it was too much like it was it was
literally too much it was so funny it
was just it's just that's really it was
really crazy and I just like I'm hating
Kenya so like it was such a great moment
like Fanon [ __ ] hilarious it was so
funny like the line is so good I mean
it's just ruining it like with she's
such a bad attitude like she just thinks
she's Teresa but worse I understand but
like Teresa was never Roz Washington so
like I understand why Nene going from
Roz Washington to just like another one
of the girls right it's just Nene like
made it out like she moved to Hollywood
like she had was a star and multiple
Ryan Murphy shows and then she had to
she was like how Stassi came back from
New York with her tail between her legs
that was nene leakes but at least Stassi
came back and humbled herself and like
still had real friendships I thought he
hadn't been on multiple Ryan Murphy
shows like Network wasn't failing but
Nene expected to come back and like just
be able to she just her attitude is -
about it and it's we're so far out from
that like it's been a year since she's
gonna marry and she still hasn't home
and also if ethany can humble herself
from having her own talk show being back
on Moroni then like anyone can do it oh
comparison from her being on shark tank
and Boronia at the same time in like
she held it you're allowed to hold that
over the other women a little bit but
like there's a line agree I think
Teresa's crossed that line I think
Nene's crossed that line I think Vicki
Gunvalson cross that line agreed okay
are you ready for our next story I am
but first I must tell you it is brought
to you by OkCupid have you ever been on
the date where you just had nothing in
common with the person a lot of people
don't know this but OkCupid is really
excuse me
changing the dating game by asking you a
ton of questions about yourself and what
type of person you're looking for the
more questions you answer the better
they are at finding your matches some of
our favorite questions from OkCupid are
a little bit more unique than the
standard dating they go beneath the
surface they ask what do you make New
Year's resolutions are you a chord
cutter Jackie would have a very
interesting thing to say about that do
you share your streaming platform
passwords with other people so basically
what I'm trying to say is they get to
know you a little bit better and
therefore get to know the people that
they're matching you with a little bit
better the best part about OkCupid is
that it works statistically it is the
most mentioned dating app in the New
York Times wedding section which I think
is so fascinating and just hearing a lot
of the toasters stories about people who
met their boyfriends girlfriends
husbands wives on okey-okey Cupid is so
cool so stop the mindless time on dating
apps and go to the app where you choose
what matters OkCupid is totally free so
we don't have an offer or like a long
link for you it's just the OkCupid app
download it today go on a great date
this week and then tell us about that
great person you met we will come to the
wedding and that is not enough I have
vowed on this show if you meet someone
on OkCupid you get married because I
told you about it I'm cover the wedding
I am performing a song I am getting
ordained I'm officiating check it out
OkCupid love it sign-on find love okay
are you ready for our next story really
crazy stuff because Jessica Simpson out
of my birthday oh my god your birthday
buddy I feel so connected to Jessica
Simpson I was gonna say Cho okay Cupid
because we had the same birthday growing
up and like everyone has a birthday
buddy but when we were like in middle
school like Jessica's everything so it's
like your birthday buddies and we try to
paper on our birthday buddies and it was
just have iconic and I really feel
connected to her and I just love her
mine was so that's that has that changed
though since new people became famous
yes I believe that Rebecca Romijn is
about the body of Rebecca Rama Jin love
her love her Rebecca Romijn O'Connell
yeah um and I think I think yes and like
new influencers on the scene right no
it's so interesting to see how like
birthday but
evolved because it's not like new people
are being born but more people are
becoming famous yeah I do not want to
see if there's anyone I love the website
famous birthday it's like because I'm on
it and then it ranks you like you are
the seven hundred thousandth most famous
person on world Wow um Emma Stone
redhead yeah wait that's so crazy I
guess she wasn't famous when we were
growing up middle school amar Odum Wow
iconic iconic I'm like not on the
homepage for November 6 birthday so
gonna be okay I need to work a little
harder can you see who's on mine I think
Jessica Simpson is probably still number
one or at least she is in my heart I
just love famous birthdays and my
picture on like my profile was so I live
for a while but they recently changed it
thanks thanks for updating on ansion
famous birthdays is really quick with
the update and they always reach out
like um if you want to add something to
your page ya know they're really but you
also don't want to seem like the type of
person who like takes their own famous
birthdays so like you have to ignore the
emails but it just no I see them you
know we see them as okay Nikola Tesla
which is crazy because he's like oh like
the old man the old man yeah from 1856
ad Wow okay I guess he beats Jessica
Simpson he's number one uh he's number
two number one is Claudia Ashraf Oh not
funny funny let me see I really thought
you were real I'm such a narcissist like
I need till I come back oh wow Harry
Edwards from Little Mix
Sofia Vergara oh what a day um who else
that we know Antonio Brown the football
player Erika Jayne oh I don't know that
yes I'm sorry
yes Erika Jaden I knew or she might be
the seventh maybe there was just now I'm
into the month of July Oh Claudia sure
yeah I think I think you're number one
in your category oh my god okay I'm
number 37 I just 37 overall 37 overall
July 10th birthday it's like I don't
think that's bad even though like I
haven't heard some of these people like
James Rolfe I haven't heard of him and
Erika Jayne being 24 like that's a shame
Lee I mean famous birthdays okay I'm on
37 like I'm really okay let's see what
it says I mean the guy scrolled for a
while on November say they called me
prolific dad social media star who's an
unforgotten ceramic cow she's gained
more than 3 million followers oh my god
trivia she married Ben saw for a gay boy
with no job and 17 her Instagram hat was
featured on voc's July 2015
man I've been doing this for a long time
that's my
accolade 2015 money 15 is a long time my
god can someone like write up a listicle
about like best podcast might put me in
it or something actually we were talking
about lists that were left off of but
BuzzFeed did like 21 podcasts with like
great reviews and we were number eight
that come highly recommended so like
people like wrote really nice paragraphs
and whoever like submitted us thank you
so much so cool like it's just it really
is an honor to be nominated it's an
honor to be nominated and just being
included with like the marking ions of
the world
thank you so much thank you so much you
guys okay let's get to our next story
about Jessica Simpson because she has a
new memoir coming out and she's
revealing that she was killing herself
with all the drinking and pills oh wow
um five years ago Jessica Simpson had an
offer to write a motivational book to
living your best life but in her heart
she knew she couldn't go through with it
quote I didn't feel comfortable talking
about myself in a way that wasn't honest
I'm a horrible liar with the upcoming
publication of her powerful memoir open
book excerpted in this week's people
Simpson reveals for the first time that
she was sexually abused as a young girl
the resulting emotional pain along with
other stressors including career
pressures led her to self-medicate with
alcohol and stimulants a dependency that
would later prompt her doctor to tell
her her life was in danger the star got
sober in November 2017 and hasn't had a
drink since Wow giving up the alcohol
was easy she says I was mad at that
bottle at how it allowed me to stay
complacent and numb therapy she says was
the hard part as she writes with work I
allowed myself to feel the traumas I'd
been through you know she's like so
iconic for so many reasons but she
really was like one of those party girls
like a Lindsay Lohan and she really
ended up on the other side like with a
happy family and a happy life and like a
huge business billion-dollar business
and I just feel like she's really a role
model like I love her and obviously like
because I'm connected to her at famous
birthdays calm but I just think she's
actually a really good person to look up
to I totally agree it's it's I think
everyone has respect for like the
business that she built but it really
feels underappreciated I feel like as a
person she doesn't get the respect that
she deserves like you don't go from
being a pop star to running a
billion-dollar business like it's not
that easy no and I don't think a lot of
people even know period about the stuff
that she went through a while at the
height of her career which is why is
important while you're battling
addiction right this is just so I just
I'm so proud of her I feel the way you
feel connected to the field you were
just saying oh - Gary Jannetty I feel
connected like my whole life
Jessica Simpson like I always felt like
if she could be a pop star like I could
because like we both were born on July
10 and he did and I become a pop star I
just love her um but they only recently
found out that her like most iconic song
angels is a cover I'm actually I'm gonna
read this book now that I have a Kindle
with yeah by the way I can't stress this
enough having a Kindle has changed my
life for the better and if you've ever
been on the fence and you're like oh I
don't read that much like you will read
more with a Kindle you just well this
isn't even sponsored by Kindle no but I
just like want to share the love because
I found it to be really great for my
mental health honestly I've been um like
falling asleep having finished having
read instead of watching TV for sure I
watch the TV on you watching then I
switched to a book I sleep so much
better
I believe tell you I'm just being like a
little sick I've been drinking so much
tea and I just have to say like I
[ __ ] 18 are you gonna spill the tea
and I hate soup soup is disgusting no
it's not it's really nasty like I think
it makes me more sick because I'm like
gagging at this nasty like chunky carrot
it's so nasty like oh my no you just go
with a broth I did I got consomme from
2nd Avenue deli and it was so disgusting
oh my god I'm sorry good tea though mmm
I'm glad you're enjoying it is that the
one the lemon one yeah it's um it's a
lemon ginger lemon zinger ooh exciting
very exciting okay final story some news
that just came in that's like really
crazy in the influencer space um kara
Santana has been completely blindsided
by her fiance Jesse Metcalfe aka
John Tucker after he cuddled up to a
make a the gardener of course after he
cuddled up to a mystery woman and held
hands with model Libya Pillman wait this
is so weird for like so many reasons one
because I honestly thought they were OTP
like I just really felt like they were
made for each other they even started to
look alike to me like they looked like
brother and sister one two it's weird
because Karen Santana is like very much
in like the the influencer model worlds
like this girl like is getting herself
blacklisted because Carsen kind of like
friends with a lot of famous no but it's
not just one girl like pictures came out
over the weekend of him with like
multiple women and it doesn't but
they're like in the street holding hands
he doesn't look like he's hiding it
nobody there's these pictures to
different person that's a different
person he went on a bender
kara Santana was
lately buying cited by reports at her
fiance Jeffy Jesse Metcalfe stepped out
with multiple women over the weekend the
35 year old designer and actress was
nowhere in sight this weekend as Jesse
stepped out with a pretty blonde after
holding hands with Hungarian model Libya
Pillman sources revealed to Daily Mail
com that Kara was blindsided by the
photographs of her fiance being
affectionate with other women kara and
Jesse have been engaged for nearly five
years after he popped the question and
on August 2016 following more than half
a decade of dating they've been together
almost 10 years um I don't know how you
come back from this unless they're in an
open relationship this is so John Tucker
honestly like I'm not really somebody's
textbook John it's textbook John Tucker
like honestly I would not be surprised
if he was out here making out with
Sophia Bush like it's just that's the
life he chose for himself a hundred
percent um yeah I wonder where they go
from here I know it's just you know what
sucks is like when they're so like well
known for being a couple like because
Jesse Metcalfe hasn't really acted a lot
he's on the Hallmark Channel so right
he's he hasn't reacted a lot and so he's
just like now when I think of Jesse
Metcalfe I think of him in his
relationship but what he's like known
for insane with having out with Olivia
culpo
on boats with Devin winters like that's
what I think about and now it's just
like what I know you for like you're
ruining what are you doing yeah unless
they do have an open relationship which
is possible but I think the blindside in
this would then be about like him
stepping out with these women and being
public about it right like if you're
gonna be it's like the Justin Timberlake
thing like if you're gonna be in an
operon relationship cool like just don't
embarrass your wife a hundred persons
not saying that they are but like it
could have been cuz those pictures were
so weird
yeah and you just never know what goes
on but don't embarrass your wife or your
friend don't embarrass the family I
agree but then it begs the question okay
they've been engaged for five years
that's really long time do you ever see
that maybe the five-year engagement no
they show batting and stuff it's just
it's so bad like oh my god it's so bad
but it's like always indicative well not
always but in them film it makes it seem
like it was indicative of something
larger so I wonder I wonder what I don't
was stopping I think that they are not
super traditional these two like they
were together five years and that's what
makes me think like maybe they might be
in an open relationship or just like
this is um this is just sad they do seem
really committed to each other so for so
long you know spent ten years with
someone to not be committed right so
this is very sad and I hope I hope she's
okay I hope she's okay too maybe she
get her makeup done on the glam app
that's what she owns yes I didn't know
that um okay we got a launch into TV
recaps because then we have dere
toasters and then we got a launch cam to
us tickets so Kara is today's TV segment
sponsor there are a wellness brand that
makes it easy to maintain your health
goals with a customized vitamin plan
that helps you feel your best today and
supports you long-term start a
resolution you can actually keep make
2020 the year to prioritize you and
commit to staying on top of your health
instead of that laundry list of
resolutions you don't end up sticking
with carob can make taking your vitamins
and supporting your health goals
attainable their quiz helps you find
vitamins and powders that will support
your specific health goals goals this
year like improving your fitness routine
or managing stress the convenient daily
packs are perfect for an on-the-go
lifestyle just throw one in your purse
or your gym bag and you're on your way
there focused on the quality science and
research that goes into each of their
products and recommendations they're
yummy protein powders are made of real
ingredients you can recognize like
organic cacao and pink Himalayan sea
salt oh man I've heard some Himalayan
sea salt is like the new thing the
individual eco-friendly packs are made
of compostable films and there's tons of
info on how to compose them on the carob
website health is made easy things to
carob on carobs online quiz take a short
online quiz to answer some of questions
about your health and your diet goals
your lifestyle and Kara will recommend a
list of vitamins and supplements
specifically designed for your health
needs and goals the vitamin aisle can be
confusing and it's hard to know where to
start answer easy questions like how
much sleep do you get how often do you
work out spoiler alert never g will
follow any specialty diets no are you
concerned about your hair skin and nail
health yes
follow care of expert recommendations or
adjust your pack at any time what you
receive is totally up to you we got an
offer for you guys because your health
is important and we're here to help you
for 50% off your first care of order go
to take care of and enter the code toast
50 the website is take care of comm and
enter the code toast 5 0 for 50% of your
first care of order take care of comm
code toast 50 sign on take care of
yourself you guys it's so important ok
let's start at the Batchelor shall we
the most boring episode and I don't know
what the episode title was but it should
have been loser on loser crime 100% I
happened to watch with Zack who like
will watch everything with me except the
bass yeah he just couldn't get out of it
he does think Aleya is
toxic yes his word toxic to the house
because it's like causing all of this
drama where do you stand on a layout who
is she fighting with opening I really
like Sydney and I think she's a nice
girl and I think she had potential and
while I know everyone was on a Sydney's
side I was on neither one of their sides
like the it seemed like the argument
really came out of thin air like there
was no like usually you're mad at
someone for things they've done like
there was no things they just a vibe it
was seeing with the Hannah Ann thing
last week it's like everyone's getting a
vibe about her but like what's the vibe
cuz her by the way and if you don't act
different on camera they need you
off-camera you're a sociopath yes I
think there is there's a certain amount
of like oh of course I want to sit up
straight I'm on camera versus being a
completely different person and there's
a few things a few reasons why this
episode went so wrong
first of all these spikes that the girls
are picking are like based on things
that they're seeing in the house that
were not seeing that happened last year
- with like Kaelyn and Hannah brown
we're like they had this fight and we
don't know what they're talking about so
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah second thing
that went wrong is everyone is - like
prematurely
calling out other people's intentions
like I'm sorry this is weak to sit down
you don't know as you need to it's like
day five right exactly like you can't
make judgments about people and Peter is
not far enough along with any of these
women to give a [ __ ] however through its
third thing that rent went wrong the way
Peter handled everything first of all
when Sydney said something to him if he
really wanted to know who what was about
he should have asked her straight up
making her call her out horrible the
whole class was so stupid it tells the
whole group that there's drama like he
literally threw her under the bus I had
to think that was something the
producers made him do and no one's ever
done that before and then he launches
this investigation into this very small
red flag that Sydney just wait for him
she wasn't saying like oh my god like
Code Red she was just like listen
there's some people here who are
different in front of the cameras and he
made it into this whole big thing I know
you know what Sydney like said and I'm
not even on a lie aside but like Sydney
set her up almost like asking her about
pageantry it was like do you feel like
you've stuck some of that like some of
that pageantry stuff it's like stuck
with you into real life and she's like
of course it was part of my life for
eight years so then she goes
Sydney's acting like a pageant queen and
you would literally asked her but I
think that was someone was like she
should have
when to a lion-like told her her
concerns that's exactly what she did and
then she told Peter um and I think that
any like if I were the lead I would have
went in Sidney said that I would have
been like who are you talking about she
would've said away I would have said
okay thank you and I just would have
kept that in the back of my mind as I
got to know a layout like you didn't
have to launch an investigation a raid
over a perception of someone you know
handle it so portly he's not sad like
like Allah was saying like it's not
facts it's just how she feels and if sin
if Peter value Sydney's opinion I would
have taken that into account if I were
him and just kept it in the back of my
mind as I got to know what I liked and
then him eliminating her just based on
what other people are saying it it is
unfair you don't even like maybe she is
this way but maybe he could still like
like her regardless of that right just
cuz she has a high-pitched voice so like
her coming back next week it's just all
so stupid no when it's also so stupid
because like I hate investing time and
arguments into girls who I know are
going nowhere like I like Sydney and
Elias whatever but like none none of
them are hometown material I joined this
point is at this point it's just like
we're talking about people who are
irrelevant yeah and like Peter is
wasting his time dealing with people who
were never gonna be like his OTP his
date with Victoria P was so cute yeah I
love her yeah and then she gets into it
next week with a pageant drama very
Hannah B and Kaitlyn but I really like
Victoria I I think just based off of
what I'm seeing I really feel like
Maddie is like frontrunner for me um and
somebody pointed out on Twitter which
they didn't really even address was when
they got one minute at the cocktail
party together or one of those parties
Hannah I'm not had a Maddie had an
envelope in her hand and it looked like
Peter was like passing her a note which
we know in bachelor history like it's
something that they do to people that
they like but maybe she was passing him
a note oh yeah if she was holding it so
oh maybe she's been waiting to give it
to him but either way these are like
cute you know I really like Maddie
even though did you see did you see the
speculation that she runs her own fan
account yes I did because she left a
comment on her own Instagram thinking
that she people think that she thought
she was on the wrong whatever people
think that she runs her own fan account
and commented what a fan account would
comment on her picture from the wrong
account now her rebuttal is that when
she went on The Bachelor her sister took
over her Instagram because they can't
have social
and it was the sister that meant to
comment it and accidentally worded on
Matty's right I saw that they like
shared an Instagram for a minute and I
saw that too which is a good explanation
but but it's just not so it's not that
far off that she would have a fan of
count like Bachelor people have so many
fan accounts now like it used to be like
only pop stars but now there's like a
million Instagram accounts for anyone
who's ever walked the earth right and
she should have a fan account but should
she be running it no I'm saying I don't
think I think that the possibility of
her having one run by someone else is
not that far off no I don't think anyone
like that she wouldn't need to run her
own no but then why would it come from
her personal account
I don't think the sister thing might be
true no but not the assistant not that
the sister is running her fan account no
that the sister accidentally left a
comment yeah I I think that that's sure
she doesn't seem like as Cersei as as
other people I don't think I know that
and I didn't think it was that crazy I'm
saying my Kenna like she's must go oh
I'm so glad like and I feel bad cuz like
every every bachelor season like there
becomes there he's always someone I
really really don't like when she was
literally Sarah Bandol was that her name
yeah when she was about to faint from
not getting a rose like weak - I'm sorry
you still don't know him like you made
out once by the way she wasn't even
freaking out about the potential loss of
Peter she was freaking out about the
potential loss of Instagram Paula it's
like she's so transparent like she's all
over ticked off now she's milking it so
much her bio is fashion bloggers it's so
it's so transparent and to me like I
feel like she's someone that I'm
supposed to like I took out this
chocolate before the show I leave it
later um and I just I don't like her
she's nothing of the sort
and she's young and she's a really good
friend of Kaitlyn Bristowe and I like
lucky are you positive about that yes oh
my god i keeps what are you not possum
i'm not positive that that's correct
oh real you know just cuz they're both
from Canada can we get come from I know
Kailyn has a friend on the show you're
saying it's my kind of but I don't think
that it is no I'm like 100% sure and why
do you call her my Kenneth and we can we
see if Kaitlyn follows McKenna
Hays ball McKenna with the cat yeah my
mic-n adjourn Jorn okay but Mimi like oh
god what kind of Falls man answer I'm
like I just I just it's this is the
thing this is the formula of The
Bachelor it's like every year there's
one person who I just literally can't
stand and it was like Sarah vandal like
never even did anything to me except
well put that horrible Instagram like
music video on her Instagram and like
just from there on out I knew she had
bad intentions and just like coming on a
fad it's a fashion blogger and just
acting like you are Romeo and Juliet and
meanwhile I like you're so irrelevant to
the storyline like you're not winning
like you might go to paradise but it's
just like acting like like like if she
doesn't get a rose ship it oh and then
like literally at the party starting
crying that she on their time like
you're irrelevant sweetie like I just I
feel that for getting up I'm on my way
that she should have behaved as like the
way that girl who got eliminated behaved
where she was just like bye run normal
person but no she was up Zacks I thought
that she was the prettiest one there the
girl Sarah who got eliminated that night
she was in a blue dress she never said
anything but she was super cute and he
was shocked that she got eliminate women
they took Google her snatchler page the
snatcher has a post about it oh yeah oh
I think I know who turned up shiny dress
when he said she was robbed the
snatchler the snatcher has all the tea
when I'm yeah with Tokyo Sarah coffin oh
what a bad last name and she's so cute
she looks like Kaitlyn Carter yeah but
she was irrelevant like she literally
never spoken like she handled herself
right because if you're gonna be
irrelevant like sit down if you're gonna
be relevant like at least be self-aware
right and I just feel like my cannon
it's just all over the place
Makenna Makenna your Kenna
no she's just not my she's not my type
of gal I don't maybe I mean there should
be something I actually did like her
take talks like I think she's a good
dancer of course um I don't know it's
just like she to me she just wants to be
what had I in is you know right now like
right it's like everything is happening
for Hannah and just because she's like
one of those girls where it's like the
world revolves around and she has a
genuine connection with Peter right and
she's a thing that my Kennet lack I
didn't know I'm the kind of things that
like she is the Hanahan yeah and she's
nothing I'm sorry somebody lied to her
several times and told her she was like
Hannah Anne and she's nothing of the
sort she's nothing like that she's
nothing like that but I'm happy for that
she stayed another week because like she
really wanted to and right and like I
wonder if your instagrams growing it
someone is keeping in its Excel
spreadsheet in the morning toasters
group about how many followers the
people are getting and McKenna has 140
so I would love to know how much she had
when she started and called herself a
vlogger I agree well I'll have to check
the spreadsheet
um love I love checking my spreadsheets
let's jump in dump into let's dive into
the ender pearls go cat for sure
I'm from pearls recap I thought it was a
good episode I think that there's so
many storylines like I'm actually having
a hard time keeping up there's so many
cast members we didn't even see James
Kennedy I was thinking the same thing
and I really had like a very visceral
reaction to like the new week House
member ones like I like Stan Dana I feel
so bad for she's still handling
everything so nice Sheena is so immature
and vindictive like just are you gonna
talk to all the girls max is talking to
her just me she's out of control I felt
really badly that I was so harsh on her
last week but then this week she was
even worse and I I don't feel badly at
all she was all so much what happened
five I watched half of it and still like
she just makes all these excuses for her
for her crazy behavior and the woman who
was sitting with her I'm watch what
happens I'd like was clearly like not on
her side right and they were talking
about the Apple watch for Thanksgiving
and the woman was like that Thanksgiving
gifts are not a thing and she was just
like I knew he really wanted in like he
was making me so happy so I got it for
him and like I don't think that that is
a strength like I just don't know buying
she doesn't in a unique position where
she's been on the show since the
beginning and she definitely is one of
the most highest paid people on the show
and she keeps dating like new Busboys
like people who she has like economic
power over and she's just like buying
them things to the chill they'll like
her but so sad
no like she's the sugar mama not Burstyn
no not at all - but no but it's like
people are giving Kristen so much [ __ ]
for the same thing scheana Cena's not
evolving yeah and even though Kristen
wasn't on this episode I have looked at
her on the show now with such fresh eyes
I'm so glad that's coming on the toes
I'm so glad because I'm now now that
I've seen this side of her from the toes
I want to just watch her behavior on the
show and even if it's stuff that I don't
agree with I might be able to understand
why she's doing what she's doing
yeah but I want to talk a minute about
like this new crew of people Charlie Oh
Charlie XCX ain't Ana what was her name
Danica sorry the suspended manager
suspended manager who by the way they're
both giving me Christina Cali vibes and
I really don't like Kristina Kelly
because even though I'm not a shiness
Ana I think like when Stassi wasn't
invited to her wedding and Christian
invited Christina Kelly over and they
were making so much fun of scheana like
I understand why Stassi had like a gripe
against scheana but Christina Kelly
didn't she was just saying mean things
to like make Stassi like her and like I
will never forget that scene the first
things such mean things about scheana on
her wedding day when like she really had
no fight machine and they were never
friends she wasn't not invited to a
wedding cuz they weren't friends they
just weren't friends yeah so I it was
giving me that vibe where like Charlie
and like this girl daneker just like
getting like saying what
scheana wants to hear so that like they
won't like Dana like it's just it was
giving me such a mean girl caddy da and
the fact that Sheena is now like the
leader of the girlies is the reason why
this sect of the show isn't gonna work
this sector this group of girls is like
Revenge of the Nerds I think I said this
last week but the fact that Sheena can't
even find new ways to like haze Dana
she's just doing exactly what Stassi did
her even like me they should on much
Rabin's live like a good screen even
down to making her recite the specials
like it's so lame it's so lame it's so
lame also the suspended manager is the
[ __ ] woat worse I can my Shan and her
ex like it looks really cute I thought
okay me he's in Cranford $1,300 okay
yeah that's really nice except for the
threesome part but you know what like
different strokes for different I think
it's that weird you live in West
Hollywood you like young and ha you want
to [ __ ] a million people but you're also
in a relationship like have a threesome
sure um I want to hear he's the breath
that I want on my show for sure like so
I hope this falls on like the right ears
yeah the newbie drama like it's it's
silly because she's like it's
frustrating to watch because scheana
sucks but it was actually meaning making
for good TV I'm like now more than ever
I'm just like ride-or-die for Dana do
you call it Revenge of the Nerds yes
that's exactly what it is it's it's
people it's like scheana was now she's
like living to be in charge like be in a
position to put someone else down
because she was put down for so the
problem is she's putting down a girl who
is just so cool and so sure yeah be put
down can't be put down and finds this
all so silly and like she's so
professional that she's gonna do her job
and do what Sheena says and not even
tattle on scheana in the way that she
could and it's just like what what am i
watching I'm watching a parallel
universe
ya know it's like literally what it's so
lame Revenge of the Nerds so lame and
then we had like the Stassi book party
drama where I was really shocked at Tom
San of all like out of control control
completely wrong Stassi was completely
right and people were saying that she
shouldn't have like screamed at him like
that she needed to scream at him
otherwise he was never gonna leave and
he's the ego and that's where I was put
on my Instagram story like that he goes
on the show we're making it unwatchable
Sandoval's ego Sheena's you know like
they just think like I understand that
they're big stars now and so don't put
them in the same pool as people I just
want to say like of all the people on
the show who could have
go like Sandoval and scheana are not it
no but Sanibel owns 5% of a poppin bar
his name is on what Santa Monica
Boulevard and that's and sassy was like
that's not enough for you and sassy was
like I ran this by 95% of the ownership
like that is up and the fact that stand
of all saying like we're open at a new
time and like we have to accompany you
like wow you're open at a time where you
would be making zero dollars and now you
have like 60 premium customers in who
like are so obsessed with the show and
this world saying I was just Stassi
wasn't paying and said you know what
stops his doing for your [ __ ] bar
like making you money like more money
than you would make on a regular hour
and at a time where you're not even open
and I'm sorry I've never owned a bar but
I do imagine being a good owner is
getting behind the bar if someone's sick
washing dishes you're an owner you do it
all you're not too good for anything but
you shop you should be the one since you
are an owner you should be so invested
in making it work and making money at
any cost and I was shocked at like the
reason and the logic coming out of Tom
Schwartz and by the way I [ __ ] always
reason and I've never seen him defend
his wife the way she defended saw co4 he
was so on the right side of history and
reasoning with Tom Sandoval and in he's
right with him and Ariana they are just
an echo chamber of negative uh
negativity um also Schwartz is always
pretty reasonable and logical he just
like can't find his voice some can get
it out and even though he never reached
a level that stand of all was ad in
terms of like anger and if I were in his
position I would have shouted at him
like he was saying all of the right
things agreed he was really the voice of
reason um and I just there were so many
like little tidbits about that made me
so angry
and I'm glad that someone told Lisa but
Tom Sandoval told Ken and was being such
a little like revisionist history yeah
like what a liar but you know that's the
good thing about this show like they do
get to the bottom of it and you know it
is all filmed so Lisa we'll see what
happened and tom was completely in the
wrong and that is not how an owner
behaves this how like a manager behaves
who just like wants to manage right just
like to have people like beneath him
yeah it was so crazy and it was really
like a different level of fighting and I
kind of understood when Stassi was like
your name is on the [ __ ] on Santa
Monica Boulevard it's like he was
definitely feeling some type of way
about his space being invaded by a star
like this was stassi's day when it's
like usually any moment at Tom Tom is
about Tom and Tom but if you truly care
about the success of your bar you should
be so grateful that as stars in your
present worse but it's like stassi's
like Ivan worked at Sur for years
everything Stassi
I was like she's arguably like a dual
motive successful one in the bunch and
none of that was handed to her from by
Lisa like her book her podcast her tour
like that's all stuff she mailed to
herself and it's a Tom Sandoval is like
making Bank on this bar Tom Schwartz
wasn't even ever working at certain like
they all really got it handed to them
and she's like out here working so
[ __ ] hard and they didn't pay they
didn't make her pay for the room and
like now he's being a dick it was really
crazy it's really it's and there felt
like she's bringing so much to Tom time
that if she had to pay them that'd be
[ __ ] weird and she's gonna pay oh
I'll go anywhere else
knocking Rises not give you the time for
a so I'll promote another barn right her
outburst was totally justified but it
was a little bit like making a scene
like whatever but that is everything but
it's her crowd there she can make a
scene in front of them if she wants she
can be however she wants she brought
those people into the bar those are her
fans I didn't think she was being bratty
or like Princess Stassi at all it's that
she was being very reasonable I thought
she was being very reasonable and I
think she Tommy and of all needed to be
had spoken to like that and embarrassed
like that in order to leave which is he
should have never showed up there in the
first place if one hand nothing to do
with the event and to like he was just
coming to start [ __ ] and he was in the
emergency room like saying same bed yeah
I'm like where was law of this episode
so hurtful to me that they would do that
to me there's just too many cast members
um you can't fit in all 19 in one
episode no and so we need to figure out
what we're gonna do from here you know
yeah we definitely need to trim some fat
and having scheana like be that like the
leader of the pack on another show just
isn't working for me um at all at all
like I like her when she's a side member
and she's funny and she like makes no
sense and it's crazy scheana right but
like when that's like the the main path
that we're taking I guess I can't get on
yeah I do need max like step up a little
bit because part of the reason why Dana
is like scheana is able to like say all
these things to Dana's because max is
telling scheana that they're not dating
well they haven't gone on their date yet
no they went on one but they went on
they hooked up already okay but like it
still isn't it's still like Dana said in
that awkward period and you're like if
max had said we're dating like she's my
girlfriend like no she's not so yeah
he's in a weird place like scheana won't
let them relax she's just smothering the
entire thing she won't let it break free
up all those texts of nice things that
he said to her like yeah they were
hooking up for a while he thought highly
of her like which is why they were me
hooking up and he showered her with
complimented me in her look she made him
look good and now she like she's gonna
embarrass him like that reading his text
messages like
I thought that was so lame and showing
up to guys tonight look like it's even
like awful stupid I can't okay that
didn't prove anything to me about like
Max and not he's a player or anything
okay let's jump into dere toasters which
is our advice segment if you have
anything you want to write please email
us to your toasters at gmail.com we
always keep it anonymous hi Jackie and
Claudia my roommate and fellow toaster
are living with a roommate from Hale it
all started in late October when our
roommate met the worst guy let's call
him Carter he's a thief drug addict has
multiple baby mamas doesn't work and is
now manipulating our friend into paying
all of his bills it started off as her
not wanting to date him because she saw
the bad things he does but he ended up
she ended up ignoring his giant red flag
waving in her face he has now moved in
taken over our house with his [ __ ] and
sleeps all day uses our things and eats
our food
he even stays there when she's gone we
have brought it up multiple times about
how we do not feel comfortable with him
being there but she yells and screams at
us and makes us makes living in this
house terrible she has dogs and leaves
him
leaves him locked up all day or leaves
them out for us to take care of we
didn't mind we don't mind taking care of
them but they are not our dogs she
ignores us and stays up all night being
allowed as she can knowing that we have
to wake up early for work we still have
six months living with her before we are
able to move to a new land we are
miserable and cannot afford to break her
lease nor do we feel like it's our job
to move out but we need advice on what
to do signed exhausted and ready for
camp toast okay oh I'm so excited to see
you there I just like you guys sometimes
have the craziest [ __ ] friends and
it's like why are you friends with these
people yeah I feel like sometimes people
talk about themselves in relationships
with like in dating relationships
they're like I'm worth more than like
the way this person's treating me and
you need to think about your friendships
that way too oh boy um you need to
either like tell him tell her to tell
him to get the [ __ ] out but that's
obviously not gonna work you need to
kick her out I'm sorry but this is not a
friend no you need to take a really
strong stand like you hack up his things
the rest of you you stand there you have
an intervention and you say listen um he
needs to leave we understand that you
are not comfortable doing not so the
both of you need to leave the dogs can
stay here yeah you have to go no take
him strong stance because you honestly
let her thrive like you've let him move
in you've let her stay up all night like
not having said anything makes her think
that she can do whatever she want when
at the end of the day she can't so you
need to take a really really strong
stand put on your power pants put on
your power suit look in the mirror - a
power stance
take a powerful scent right and you know
what if she doesn't if it gets to a
point where like you're not going
remember and she's not um she's not
leaving then why don't you guys leave
say okay you can get stuck with the
least you can grow around for the next
six months by yourself because we're not
living like this I was gonna say that
but it's like who's name is on the lease
cuz then you could like end up like
getting a debt collector on your door
yeah that's true hopefully it's her name
lease
yeah ideally that would be yeah if it is
scram just go to camp chose to stay
there for a few months and then you go
yeah I'm okay you guys can need to get
better friends though I'm sorry like ya
know this is unacceptable
I'm assuming most of you writing in like
you live on your own you're not in
college like you're adult and if you
have adult friends who are acting like
this like they need not be your friends
agreed sometimes it's just like it's not
much paying and like dating a guy who's
like not the best is one thing but
dating a guy who like is a thief drug
addict
the Carter is getting out on on payments
to his children like yeah that's it's
different right this is actually like a
bad person like a criminal
yes okay it's like we just don't like
him for you right right that's harder to
implement change but when it's like a
drug-dealing thief
living on your couch you have the right
to say something all right next one dear
toasters I was best friends with this
girl for ten years we were practically
sisters three years ago I met a guy and
instantly we clicked and have been
together ever since
we have a dog and recently just moved
into our first home together when I
started dating him she always seemed
jealous and we started to go apart he's
the furthest thing from an [ __ ] and
so beyond kind so I never understood why
she didn't like him she's the same age
as me and has never had a boyfriend so
part of me thought that maybe she didn't
know how to handle her best friend
getting into a serious relationship but
yet she also made comments about liking
him then she became very and vindictive
and mean out of nowhere she never
supported my relationship and so we grew
apart a little bit this past year I had
a huge medical scare and I ended up
needing multiple brain surgeries anyways
during this time she was completely
ghosting me she never visited me in
recovery or texted me to see how I was
doing so I decided to end the 10-year
long friendship we haven't talked since
June but recently she's starting to tell
all of our mutual friends lies about
stuff that I said so they basically
stopped being friends with me I'm 27 and
don't want nor need that petty drama in
my life but I don't know how to handle
it because how can someone who is
basically my sister be doing this to me
right now love you both okay I'm so
letting you ended your friendship with
her because when people don't show up
for you in the most critical of times
that's not your friend because what
friends are for is to help you get
through anyone can be a friend when the
time is when the times when it's easy
when it's good
times we're having fun but like to be a
friend through brain surgery like that's
when you need to step up so like if she
wasn't there for you she was never your
friend it seems like she's really okay
with not being this girl's friend right
okay so now how do you deal with the
fact that she's like basically canceling
you around oh god um there's a few ways
to approach this one I think one way to
start is to meet with everyone like
one-on-one and just sort of like get
your side of the story out there if you
care about these friendships um and also
if she really is as crazy as she seems
like they will realize it soon enough
like you kidnapped like you can only
hide your crazy up until a certain point
but everyone's true colors eventually
come out so like if she is getting these
friends like she will eventually [ __ ]
them over and they'll know that like she
was the crazy person but if you don't
have the patience to wait that long and
like raise your friends I would just
start like hanging out with them one on
one two on one and maybe just sharing
your side of the story because I think
when you hear it's like even on the show
well like some two people are in a fight
or housewives are like you know James
Charles Tati you hear one side and
you're like oh my god we're dummies
right but then James comes and speaks
and he tells his side and and it's like
oh wait it's not so clear right this may
be like maybe they'll still be friends
with her but they won't completely drop
you right there's a lot to say about
just civil discourse you know talking
about yeah I feel like people donors in
this day and age people are just so
hopped like hot to like hop on a
bandwagon but if they're real friends I
believe you yeah and like if you have
one of them who's just like you're
closer with or you think you'll get
right
you'll then once she joins the rest of
the group like she can speak on your
behalf I wouldn't worry about it too
much you seem like you're living a nice
life like you and your boyfriend got the
dog you got a house like invest in that
like that's your future that's your
family and also like I am also 27 years
old and if someone if the next friend of
mine was going around to my real friends
like making them not be friends with me
anymore and like they didn't know me
well enough to know the person that I am
that wouldn't be true then I would be
like you guys are [ __ ] morons no I'm
I'm at if one of my closest friends like
could believe like random lies about me
from one of our other friends like
remember that from some crazy [ __ ]
right you were never really my friend
and like knowing that I've had like
brain surgeries over the past year so
like writing I'm struggling I don't have
time to make you talk [ __ ] about you
right you didn't even have the time the
time so that's that's where we're at
speaking of time it's 11:30 chem twist a
section 11:30 one camcos tickets are
being released in 29 minutes if we're
where we can post a link
the link will be posted on our Instagram
bio Instagram stories Facebook theater
group yeah just check any of our
Instagram stories twelve o'clock the
vent bright link will go up and the
password you need the password to get to
the Eventbrite links to that like we
don't have random people from Eventbrite
like just who's looking for events show
to get until nhd toasters only so yeah
where's the password password is gonna
be on our Instagram stories in our
Instagram it'll be everywhere can't miss
it and it's it's a great pass we are so
excited to see you guys tomorrow and at
Camp tous and tonight at my show at
Caroline's for me show is at 11:30 yeah
okay yeah this week the rest of the
shows to speaker gonna be at different
times because I need to sleep vocal rest
if three shows this week so I don't know
if I mentioned I'm performing I'm at the
Beacon Theater 11:30 tomorrow Thursday
and Friday show will be at 12:30 and
Michelle Caroline's tonight is sold out
but my show in Inglewood on Thursday is
actually like 25 seats left so if you
want to come it's really cute theater I
think you guys will have a good time
just want to put that out there thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast millennium morning show where we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube thank you so much
please feel free to subscribe leave a
comment you know about how cute we are
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
about if I iTunes stitcher public video
I her video Cass boxy could Obie's go
for those five star reviews oh right
iTunes so wherever you listen to
podcasts please leave a five star review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we love you guys so much we will
see you tomorrow bye